ça va vous écouter aujourd'hui on va
faire un exercice qui est dingue moi à
mes yeux c'est un exercice de fou qu'on
va faire et pourtant c'est un exercice
que genre la plupart d'entre vous
avaient probablement déjà fait je
m'explique j'ai commencé youtube quand
j'étais en seconde
arrivé au terminal ça marchait super
bien pour moi je gagnais déjà un salaire
tous les mois et tout à l'heure j'étais
en terminale la folie mais je savais pas
encore si j'allais faire ça à plein
temps après avoir eu mon bac j'avais un
autre projet qui était si j'avais mon
bac de postuler dans des écoles
publiques d'audiovisuel ce que j'ai fais
aucune hockey comme ma chaîne youtube
marché déjà vachement bien et que
j'avais un an d'avancé sur ma scolarité
javel excuse parfaite pour dire à mes
parents là je fais ce que je veux pour
dorian et vous avez rien à dire ce que
mes parents m'ont répondu par le fdp
mais ok mais si jamais ma chaîne youtube
n'avait pas pris j'avais quand même un
autre projet sous coude et ce projet les
amis c'était le projet d'une vie c'était
le rêve d'un gamin c'était être vendeur
un micromania
qu'est ce que tu as à faire maintenant
l'un de mes rêves était de vendre des
jeux vidéo vraiment bats les couilles
combien ça paye je veux bande des jeux
vidéo c'est tout et pour arriver à ce
métier de vendeur dans un magasin de
jeux vidéo j'aurais dû passer par les
rouages classique par lesquels je ne
suis jamais passé le combo faire un cv +
lettre de motivation + entretien
d'embauché
c'est ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui on
va faire comme si j'avais pas eu le cul
bordé nouilles et ma chaîne youtube
n'avait pas pris et du coup j'allais
devoir faire un cv et une lettre de
motivation et un autre tiers dans gauche
dans le but d'obtenir ce poste de
vendeur dans un magasin de jeux vidéo ma
seule expérience avec ce truc là c'est
le stage de troisième que j'avais fait
j'avais dû faire une lettre de
motivation pas un cv mais juste une
lettre de motivation et j'étais
tellement motivé que mon stage je les
fais à intermarché c'est bon
et franchement j'avais qui fait en plus
il était cool genre si tu possèdes bien
en fin de semaine
il donnait 50 euros je les ai pas eus
c'est très mal bossé depuis j'ai jamais
refait tous ces trucs classiques je sais
pas comment ça marche donc je vais
devoir me renseigner faire ça sous vos
yeux ébahis et ensuite on va passer un
faux entretiens d'embauché avec lauren
qui connaît bien dès lors des entretiens
d'embauché puisque l on a fait pas mal
avant de devenir auteur comme elle est
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
je vous avais déjà l'impression tout ce
qu'ont déjà fait cv lettre de motivation
et tout envoyez moi votre force s'il
vous plaît soyez indulgents et tous les
autres prenez-en de la graine personne
juge s'il vous plaît comment rédiger un
cv et le présenter pour qu'il donne
envie aux recruteurs de vous rencontrer
et les convainc que vous êtes le
candidat idéal prenez une heure ou deux
pour peaufiner votre cv mais j'ai pas ce
temps là devant moi commencer par lui
donner un titre
ce titre est indispensable car ce n'est
pas aux agriculteurs de deviner pour
quelque chose vous postulez vente vente
d'amusement virtuel et je vais être
vendeur quoi fait pas chez un cv bien
présenté avec un peu de couleurs donnent
envie aux recruteurs de le lire on peut
mettre les logos des grandes entreprises
dans lesquelles on a travaillé
ouais mais attends là on part du
principe que jeune avoir le bac genre
j'ai jamais travaillé de ma vie j'ai
aucune experts professionnels par contre
je vais qu'au début du jeu vidéo
j'ai regardé toutes les vidéos de jd
gêné tous les replays de mystère est
levé georges me connais bien je suis
rodé ça va être dur
et y'a pas des cv tout fait attendez
créez votre cv en ligne
c'est quoi ça as tu choisi un modèle
mais c'est incroyable je donne le pire
exemple à des milliers de jeunes qui
vont faire un cv dans les prochaines
années on est là mais ça c'est que des
template tout est déjà fait juste à
remplir mais c'est merveilleux
il est pas mal suis là attendez je crois
que j'ai trouvé un template qui me
convient de ouf
il est sobre il ya des petites touches
vite fait de design voilà c'est assez
cool et surtout ya un graphique et j'ai
l'idée d'un truc peut être un peu drôle
et qui peut faire kiffer la personne en
face à la photo d'identité c'est vrai
attends je vends une sérieuse devant un
mur blanc elle donne pas envie voilà je
vais soumettre une photo
ouais mais en même temps faut pas que je
fasse le gars trop extraverti genre si
je suis là et qu'une manette georges et
c'est trop de prouver quelque chose non
je te dis que j'aime les jeux vidéo
point tu vas pas me casser les couilles
sinon je serais en marché chez score
game c'est tout
[Musique]
lucas au chat @ passion.fr moi c'est la
passion avant tout quoi mon numéro on va
mettre un fait vendeur mais je suis pas
quoi même quand tu vas être vendeur de
jeux vidéo ben voilà vendeurs
spécialisés en jeux vidéo c'est pas mal
non présentation je m'appelle lucas
hochart fils de l'excellent père je le
fais des blagues partout fonction faut
que ce soit sérieux je suis passionné de
jeux vidéo depuis mon plus jeune âge et
j'aimerais transmettre cette passion à
travers la vente de ces derniers
expérience professionnelle présentation
des expériences professionnelles en
commençant par la plus récente pour
chaque emploi stage intéressant de
retrouver des informations suivantes
date métiers exercés nom de l'entreprise
et sa localisation
call of duty modern warfare 2 4 news ces
25es d'affilée sans mourir c'est chaud
dark souls un terminé à 100% sans
pleurer c'est faux j'ai jamais joué mais
elle pourra pas vérifié hockey formation
présentation du cursus en commençant par
un diplôme le plus récent avec les
informations suivantes année académique
diplôme
ouah mais j'ai pas je viens d'avoir le
bac brevet des collèges attendant c'est
du plus récent au plus vieux donc déjà
ses baccalauréats es13 lui de moyenne
malgré une addiction total à vous et
tout ce qu'on joue à wow vous savez à
quel point c'est un miracle et c'est
tout j'ai rien d'autres malheureusement
wa on peut dire je suis allé à l'école
de la vie non non je peux pas je peux
pas je peux pas la partie drôle ça peut
être ce graphique en fait genre cij mais
évolution de ma passion pour les jeux
vidéo
au fil du temps et ya un graphique genre
qui montre l'évolution c'est drôle donc
lucas va envoyer son cv et sa lettre de
motivation par mail
là je vais découvrant que en tant que
moi en tant que meilleur pote juste pour
rire parce que à la base on a eu cette
idée du fait qu'il n'a jamais fait de sa
vie j'avais l'expérience professionnelle
et moi c'est tout un verre j'ai fait
énormément de cv énormément d'entretien
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je vais lui
faire passer un entretien
juste après pour pouvoir l'entraîner et
qui voit à quoi ça ressemble surtout je
pense qu'il peut se débrouiller ce qui
m'inquiète plus c'est le contenu
vraiment qu'est ce qui va mettre en
expérience qu'est ce qu'il va mettre en
on est tu dans ta tion
c'est ça ou je suis curieuse il est
passé par un site où ces préfets je
pense mais c'est ça reste au convenable
c'est un peu sombre mais c'est sympa
c'est un peu originale jai eu pierre on
a une photo peut-être un peu sombre la
photo voilà peut-être un peu plus joyeux
qui l'inspirent un peu plus confiance
parce qu'à la spécialiste de la vente
est ce que tu es sûr de toi j'ai pas
convaincu je pense que je reviendrai là
dessus pendant l'entretien
en tout cas ils expliquent dès le début
que sa passion ses jeux vidéo donc ça le
ton est donné
dofus world of warcraft plus de 4000
heures de jeu c'est une expérience à lui
casser après ça m'étonne pas lui mais
c'est pas forcément ça qu'on attend dans
la catégorie expérience elle dit moi je
pense pas ok en fait je pense qu'il
s'est mis dans la peau d'un maquereau
passionnés en fait non c'est lui il
aurait pu répondre ça j'aurais préféré
voir ses compétences en mode aussi par
l'anglais si ces services de
l'informatique faut toucher enfin ce
genre de truc intéressant c'est bien
mais je sais pas comment je vais dire à
me paraît un bon on est bien ça fait le
taff un façon je mise tout sur la blague
du graphique d'accord si la personne en
voyant ça fait c'est mort si elle fait
c'est gagné lettre de motivation ya pas
d template la lettre de motivation
complète votre cv est de vous permettre
de décrocher un entretien d'embauché en
vous démarquant des autres candidats
elle indique vos points forts est ce qui
vous a incité à rejoindre cette
entreprise note relative peut vous aider
à rédiger un courrier efficace joe
hockey excellent j'ai juste à compléter
tout ça aussi excellent madame monsieur
je suis un jeune homme de 18 ans
passionné depuis toujours par les jeux
vidéo en plus d'être un fils et les
clients de votre chef de magasin est un
grand amateur de par le monde et vu un
sans faute pour l'instant je suis un
gros [ __ ] là ouais mais c'est le but
pour toucher les gaules ah ok deuxième
paragraphe j'ai fait un truc bien cela
fait maintenant trois ans que je partage
cette passion sur internet via des
vidéos sur youtube par conséquent malgré
ma faible expérience professionnelle
simple titulaire d'un bac es je suis
capable de m'exprimer aisément et de
convaincre un client d'acheter non pas
l'édition classique d'un jeu mais bel et
bien les ions collector dont l'écart de
prix est souvent en aucun cas justifier
par le bonus in game
ça c'était super
ok 3e paragraphe la consécration ultime
de cette passion serait de pouvoir en
vivre
et si cela pouvait se faire au sein de
l'enseignent aux couleurs bleu cela me
remplit de joie ou bien entendu je me
battrai corps et âme
ce quelqu'un de même pour viser un
chiffre d'affaires toujours plus haut au
moins il est motivé
dans l'attenté de vous rencontrer
prochainement pour pouvoir vous exprimer
ma plaine motivation je vous prie de
croire madame monsieur l'expression de
mes salutations distinguées
pierre du bien du tout bon je viens
d'écrire la [ __ ] de lettres de
motivation je suis assez content moi je
vais préparer mon entretien d'embauché
apprendre à réussir notre entretien
d'embauché grâce au merveilleux site oui
car préparer l'entretien d'embauché à
l'avance effectuer des recherches sur
l'entreprise la première chose que vous
avez à faire après avoir obtenu un
entretien d'embauché pour un poste et de
se renseigner sur l'entreprise hockey au
micromania zinc
c'est ça le vrai nom complet j'ai même
pas là je vais gagner des points et on
voit que c'est un vrai passionné et des
jeux vidéo et de leur magasin dix ans sa
société française créée en 1983 par
harbert laury dance président abonde de
jeux vidéo ok bon bah ça y est j'ai
assez neuf mais ça malgré un jeu vidéo
ou quoi mais on va pas faire genre c'est
bon habillez-vous de manière
professionnelle
si vous voulez faire bonne impression
vous devez commencer par bien vous
habiller ah ouais ça je crois que j'ai
une chemise je crois que j'ai une
chemise je crois que j'ai une cravate
avec présentez-vous avec confiance faux
et dire quelque chose de simple comme je
m'appelle suzanne merci pour tant que
vous me consacrer au quai articulé quand
vous répondez aux questions ça c'est ma
spécialité des quatre passages c'est
très particulier de parler très vite en
fait pas assurez vous de remercier les
membres du jury hockey ne dit rien qui
puisse montrer que vous connaissez pas
grand chose à propos de l'entreprise
sans blague ok bon bref vas-y je vais
improviser de façon ça ça ira je suis
pas trop mauvais en orale la tenue ben
je suis prêt je suis prêt pour le rendez
vous au juste c'est ce que je veux faire
plutôt que d'être sur fond vert je mette
une chambre de mes gars passionné
c'est comme si j'avais genre une
collection de jeux vidéo de malades des
armoires à voilà alors ça c'est vraiment
une bonne idée ça c'est une vraie douche
mais bon la personne en face et ali
verra que du feu au juge jamais qu'elle
vient de chez moi ok lorraine va arriver
d'un moment à l'autre faut vraiment je
sais que c'est un entraînement et ses
pingouins coûteuse mais faut vraiment
faire comme si c'est un volet entretien
il faut que je sois bon je veux vraiment
réussir cet entretien vous comprenez
c'est parti bonjour bonjour lucas
hochart c'est ça c'est ça merci de
prendre le temps pour cet entretien
aujourd'hui envoyer par mail votre cv et
lettre de motivation
effectivement j'ai pris le soin de les
regarder en amont mais j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur certains points ensemble
avec grand plaisir
je vais vous demander avant tout de vous
présenter eh ben je m'appelle le chaos
charge passionnait jeu vidéo joue
beaucoup au jeu vidéo depuis depuis mon
plus jeune âge par votre collection
n'est ce pas ah oui c'est toute ma
collection vous voulez c'est l'étiquette
dessus et tout bien sûr neuf sous
blister comme un vrai passionné
d'accord on passe sur votre cv nous vous
définissez dans votre charge comme
spécialiste de vente jeux vidéo je vois
néanmoins
précisément aucune expérience dans la
porte oui bah j'ai en fait je viens
juste d'avoir mon baccalauréat
effectivement j'ai jamais vendu vu que
très jeune mais je pense que pour voir
il faut avant tout savoir bien
s'exprimer et de par mon expérience sur
youtube et des vidéos que j'ai fait
c'est quelque chose que je gère assez
bien je suis assez à l'aise et je sais
bien tendre la main aux gens quoi
d'accord j'ai apprécié le petit
graphique sur l'évolution de votre
passion pour les jeux vidéo chez du
temps après est-ce que vous avez
d'autres passions éventuellement à
partager dans la vie je n'aime que le
jeu vidéo
dans un premier temps j'aimerais que
vous me donniez une qualité et un défaut
qualité c'est cette envie d'amener les
gens la foule qualité c'est cette envie
de créer du lien avec les gens et
partager quelque chose avec eux et
défauts je dirais que c'est que je parle
beaucoup maintenant j'aimerais savoir
pourquoi vous êtes venus vers nous et
pourquoi pas une autre enseigne parce
que moi j'adore microsoft faisait la dea
visuel déjà de la marque est super bien
et c'est pas du tout parce que ce corps
games a fait faillite et cas que
micromania c'est ça n'a aucun rapport
on va se concentrer sur la notion de
vente j'aimerais que vous me voyez
maintenant un jeu vidéo mais attention
j'aimerais que vous me vendirent édition
collector très bien bas on peut on peut
prendre comme exemple par exemple gta 5
qui est juste ici un jeu de chez
rockstar ils ont sorti une édition
collector de ce jeu là dans lequel tu as
de l'argent dans le mode en ligne est
une voiture exclusive qui était très
bien pour frimer devant dans les autres
joueurs et se sentir mieux et c'est
vraiment le jeu l'une des plus grandes
références de danse jeux vidéo à l'heure
actuelle quoi par exemple call of duty
gosse lui et le pire call of jamais créé
je sais pas si vous saviez mais le pire
ça vous n'êtes pas obligé de le préciser
au qui ont par exemple nécessaire on
tient un niveau du salaire en tant que
vendeur non je pense qu'en vue de
mon expérience dans le jeu vidéo je
pense que je devrais autour des 4000
euros quoi ok vous postulez pour un cdi
chez nous nous ce qu'on peut vous
proposer c'est de commencer un peu plus
bas mais il ya évidemment des prix mais
comme cette très motivés et très
passionné vous y aurez sûrement haxaire
sont super g verra dernier point à voir
avec toute votre lettre de motivation
est signée par pierre dupont oui et
c'est donc pierre anne bon c'est bien ça
non un pierre du pont pierre dupont
exactement pyrale bon c'est son frère
c'est les deux héros dans rayman légende
juste ici voilà ce n'est en aucun cas et
je pèse mes mots
une lettre de motivation que j'ai pris
sur le net et dans laquelle j'ai oublié
de retirer la signature avant trouvant
termine cet entretien à il faut savoir
que vous êtes plusieurs à postuler pour
ce poste cdi
j'aimerais donc savoir pourquoi je
devrais me prendre goût et pas un autre
parce qu'ils n'ont pas cette étagère
sûrement du coup je pense qu'on est bon
je vous tiendrais au courant par
téléphone et bien je vous remercie
je vous remercie pour cet entretien mais
c'est d'avoir écouté la a pris le temps
de le faire avec plaisir et je ne
souhaite pas un bon retour chez vous
parce que vous y êtes déjà
surveillez votre beauté mais je crois
qu'il y avait un bouton de valider quand
tu mets fin à la réunion
non ça s'était bien passé eh bien
écoutez j'ai adoré cet exercice c'est
incroyable affaire c'est fou comme c'est
stressant bordel je suis content d'avoir
fait ça même pour de faux une fois dans
ma vie j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de
chance avec youtube et des fois je me
dis [ __ ] mais j'ai pas vécue serait ce
que deux ans de vie normal que 15 mai de
18 ans ou 20 ans a en fait mois à 18 ans
j'ai tout de suite fait une année
youtube je gagne tout de suite vraiment
bien ma vie et j'ai tout de suite eu mon
indépendance enfin bref j'ai brûlé
beaucoup d'états de ma jeunesse
finalement professionnels et franchement
ça m'a fait plaisir du coup de fer pour
deux fois un cv une lettre de motivation
à man si j'avais dû le faire pour de
vrai je me serais plus appliqués que ça
mais en tout cas ça aurait été dans
cette veine-là de trucs à calais un peu
du
de trucs des machins et c'est con parce
que je pense que ça marche pas je pense
que c'est pas payant du tout de faire ça
en tout cas bon courage à tous ceux qui
font des études ou tous ceux qui sortent
d'études et qui font ça pour de vrai
c'est une vraie épreuve très stressante
et difficile à mener je trouve donc
voilà gros respect à vous pour ça je
vous fais des gros bisous n'oubliez pas
je parle comme d'autres mamans en fin de
vidéo
portez vous bien à très vite
[Musique]